[Music]
foreign
I'm excited to be the instructor of the
upcoming Workshop designing data
visualizations to successfully tell a
story and deposit Confluence in Chicago
this September in this course you will
learn how to create competing Graphics
to communicate your data in a clear and
effective way with a focus on your main
insights by guiding and engaging the
viewer so here are three main reasons
why you don't want to miss this Workshop
understand the importance of the context
in your audience
we will cover how to tailor your
visualization to your audience and why
it's important to consider the context
in which these visualizations are
presented this will hopefully help you
to create more effective and engaging
Graphics in the future when
communicating with data
learn how to pick a suitable
visualization to transport your message
we will discuss the strength and
weaknesses of different chart tapes and
how to pick and design a visualization
that presents the data in an honest way
but with a clear focus on your main
story
Master colors and type faces when
designing data realizations you will
learn how to avoid pitfalls and how to
effectively communicate with data by
picking suitable color palettes and a
good combination of colors and fonts to
not only transport your main message but
also the right emotion
during the course you will also have the
chance to meet like-minded people
exchange about your current projects and
get feedback on your visualizations
thanks to individual and group exercises
this sounds interesting to you then
don't miss the chance and join us at the
positive conference in Chicago
[Music]